since no man's sky launch for PC on
August 12 players have reported a myriad
of issues including crashes corrupt
saves and getting stuck under worlds
well good news space explorers hello
games has detailed the patches they've
released that address around seventy
percent of the current reported issues
details of the three patches for PC were
published on the game steam community
page patch one was focused on adding
greater support for hardware to maximize
the amount of people who are able to
experience the game this patch include
AMD phenom support mouse smoothing which
is helpful for players with sub 30
frames per second performance a fix for
frame stuttering due to the maximum FPS
cap and a solution to prevent safe
corruption patch to aim to increase
stability by addressing the most player
reported bugs and crashes the major
issue addressed in this patch was a
solution for players who found
themselves stuck under a world after
being shot down in a planet's atmosphere
this will no longer occur and if you are
currently stuck in subterranean
purgatory the game will detect this and
do its best to rescue you there've also
been fixes to crashes after warping
crashing while scanning crashing after
warping to a battle and winding up
inside a freighter and the game failing
to save until you died patch 3 targeted
the most common support requests while
also attempting to help players who have
become stranded or have corrupted save
files players who found themselves
stranded in a space station with a
busted ship and without the required
resources to repair it should find this
issue remedied along with the ability to
hopefully load corrupted saves fixes for
the three most reported issues the game
crashing due to a large amount of
discoveries a possible crash when a
player would collect a large number of
blueprints in a specific order and a
crash on the galactic map that would
occur if a player had set a large number
of waypoints have also been addressed
hello games has reiterated they will get
to work on new no man's sky features as
soon as the current issues with the pc
version have been fixed they wanted to
say that they expect to release at least
one major update next week no man's sky
director Sean Murray announced prior to
the game's launch that the ability to
build bases and own giant space Raiders
will be added to the game in the future
he has also revealed in an interview
with The Daily Star that suggesting the
game would only receive free updates
after launch was perhaps a little naive
are you interested to see what this
week's update brings to the game and how
are you finding the game aside from its
performance let me know in the comments
or find me on Twitter and for everything
you need to know about Daft Punk Jim
Henson puppets and restrictive inventory
systems keep coming by gamespot